so building interactive experiences on
the web today usually involves sending
some JavaScript down to your users often
quite a lot of it today we're going to
talk about some strategies you can use
to deliver that JavaScript efficiently
while still giving users a really great
experience so I work on a web browser
called chrome and when users access your
site you're probably sending down a lot
of files from web browsers perspective
this looks a little bit like this it
gets even worse with h2 multiplexing so
my perspective is that as much as I love
JavaScript it may be the most expensive
part of your site by 4-byte javascript
is probably the most expensive resource
or shipping down to your users today and
I'd like to explain why I feel like that
so the median web page today is
currently shipping down about 350
kilobytes of minified and compressed
JavaScript uncompressed that bloats up
to about a megabyte of script now the
experiences that are shipping down this
much JavaScript are taking anywhere
between fifteen to thirty six seconds to
get interactive on mobile devices now
although I've said 3358 kilobytes here
the reality is that if we take a look at
popular sites they're actually shipping
down a lot more script than this we're
hitting this ceiling across both desktop
and mobile web where sites are often
shipping multiple megabytes worth of
code that a browser then needs to
process now the impact that this can
have on loading a web page is some weird
and wonderful quirks so the way that we
take a look at loading a web page today
is that it's a little bit of a journey
it's kind of like a filmstrip that has
three key moments in it there's is it
happening is it useful and is it usable
is it happening is the moment where you
were able to deliver some painted
content to the screen so these you can
actually tell hey this web page is
loading up is it useful as the point
where you've painted content full text
or something that allows the user to
derive value from the experience and
then is it usable as the moment when a
user can actually start tapping around
the experience and having something
happening so I mentioned this term
interactive earlier but what does that
actually mean or for a page to be
interactive it has to be capable of
responding quickly to user input
whether users clicking on a link or
scrolling through a page they need to be
able to see that something's actually
happening in response to those taps and
those actions that they're making an
experience that isn't able to live Iran
this is going to frustrate your users
now one place where this can commonly
happen is when folks are server-side
rendering their experiences and then
shipping a whole bundle of JavaScript
down right after to populate and hydrate
that experience out now when a browser
needs to run many of the events that
you're probably going to need it's
probably going to do it on the same
thread that handles user input now that
thread is called the main thread or the
UI thread if you happen to be shipping
down lots of expensive javascript that
can end up blocking the main thread so
let's take a look at what you expect
will probably happen so here's an
example where you know maybe you're
going to go and tap around the UI you
might check a check box or click a link
and everything's going to work perfectly
fine but if we simulate blocking the
main thread
nothing's able to happen at the moment
we're not able to check that checkbox
any links that we click are not
necessarily going to do we expect
because we're blocking that thread so
you want to start moving away from doing
those types of things now this idea of
JavaScript impacting interactivity is
something we're seeing across lots of
different types of sites too much
JavaScript in general can actually delay
interactivity for visible elements and
this is a problem for many sites
including Google so we run into this in
sites like Google search so here are a
few examples where you know you could
start tapping around the UI but if we're
shipping too much JavaScript down there
could be some delay in there before
something actually happens and the user
may end up feeling a little bit
frustrated so that's an experience that
we want to move away from when it comes
to time to interact if we feel it you
should probably be getting interactive
in about under 5 seconds there's nothing
actually on this person's screen here so
they may be going through withdrawal
symptoms of some sort ideally we'd love
to shift the web to a position where
we're designing a little bit more for
resilience interactivity can heavily
impact a lot of things it can be
impacted by a person loading your web
site on a mobile data plan or coffee
shop Wi-Fi or just them being on the go
and not necessarily having it can
assistant network connection and when
this happens and you have a large
payload of JavaScript that needs to be
processed they can end up waiting for
the site to actually render anything or
if something does render they can be
waiting a long time before they can
actually tap around and have something
happen
ideally shipping less JavaScript would
lead to a point where they're not
necessarily running into those cases now
to explain why javascript is such a big
deal and why it can have such a large
cost I'd like to walk you through what
happens when you send content down to a
browser so a user goes and they types in
an address bar in a type sent undressing
to their omnibox their address bar a
request is made out to a server which
will then have to return some markup the
browser needs to parse that markup and
get out the CSS the JavaScript the
images that are necessary and then the
browser actually has to process all of
those resources this is actually an
accurate depiction of what happens in
chrome when we're trying to process
everything that you send down now
although this looks great one of the
challenges here is that JavaScript can
actually end up being a bottleneck so
ideally we want to be able to paint
pixels quickly and then have the page
interactive but if javascript is a
bottleneck you can end up just looking
at something that you can't actually tap
around with an experience so we want to
move away from JavaScript itself being a
bottleneck to modern experiences one
thing to keep in mind as an industry is
that if we want to be fast at JavaScript
we actually have to be fast at
downloading that script parsing it and
compiling it that means that we have to
be fast at the network transmission side
of things but also the processing side
of things for our scripts because if
you're spending a long time parsing and
compiling script in a JavaScript engine
that can delay how soon a user can
interact with your experience now to
provide some data about this here is a
breakdown of where v8 the JavaScript
engine in chrome actually spends its
time while is trying to load up a page
containing script so in the orange we
have all the time being spent parsing
the JavaScript the popular sites are
sending down in yellow is the time we
spend compiling and together these take
up anywhere up to 30% of the time it
takes us to load up the JavaScript for
your page this is a real cost now
another thing to keep in mind with
JavaScript
is that all bytes are not equal when it
comes to the web 200 kilobytes of
scripts and 200 kilobytes worth of image
have very different weights they might
take the same amount of time to download
but when it comes to processing we're
dealing with very different amounts of
costs a JPEG image needs to be decoded
rasterized eventually get painted on the
screen a JavaScript bundle needs to be
downloaded and then parse compiled
executed there are a number of other
steps that an engine needs to complete
just be aware that these costs are not
quite equivalent and one of the reasons
why these costs start to add up and
matter is mobile so mobile itself is a
spectrum many of us here today probably
have a high-end or median end phone and
the realities that our users may not
necessarily have those device classes
they may be on a low-end phone they may
be on a median phone and the disparity
between these multiple classes of
devices can be quite stark due to
thermal throttling differences in cache
sizes CPU GPU you can end up
experiencing quite different processing
times for resources like JavaScript
depending on the device you're using so
here's a breakdown of how long it takes
to parse JavaScript from a range of
different types of devices at the very
top we have high end devices which
generally process it pretty quickly the
very bottom we've got our low end
devices and in the middle we've got our
average phones so things like the Moto G
4 or the Moto G 5 now take a look at how
much longer that script takes the
process we can we can actually try to
look at a more practical version of this
so here is the JavaScript startup time
and processing time for CNN comms
JavaScript on an iPhone 8 using the a 11
processing chip that they have it takes
9 seconds less to process JavaScript
then it does an average phone nine
seconds that's nine seconds quicker that
that experience would be loading and
interactive on an iPhone than something
more average this hints at another thing
that maybe we need to stop necessarily
taking fast networks and CPU and high
RAM for granted fast devices can
actually sometimes be slow you can be
running multiple things on there fast
networks can be slow variability can end
up making absolutely
everything's slow you may have users
that you know are not going to have the
the latest and greatest phone they might
have something more average and so it
becomes really important for us to start
testing on real phones and real networks
so if your team were able to take a look
at their annelids and understand exactly
what devices your users are actually
accessing your site with that'll give
you a hint at what devices you should
probably have in the office to test out
your experiences using if you're not
able to afford those you just can't get
approval for it check out webpagetest
slash easy we have a number of profiles
set up there that you can go and use
today that already have popular devices
can pre-configured we've got some median
mobile devices like the Moto G 4 already
in there and it's also really important
to test on representative networks now
although I've been talking about you
know the notion of low end and median
phones being important
Brian Holt made this really great point
yesterday which is it's really important
to know your audience not every single
site it needs to work great on 2g on a
low-end phone you may well have a wide
range of users on sort of the higher end
of the spectrum or in a different part
of the spectrum so just be aware of the
data behind your sites that you can make
a reasonable call on how much all of
this matters so if you want to be faster
JavaScript download times are going to
be pretty critical for low end networks
the things you can do there are just
ship less code minify your source take
advantage of compression so gzip broadly
za fly take advantage of caching for
repeat visits parse times are pretty
critical for phones that have a slower
CPU now on the server if you're sort of
a back-end developer a full stack
developer you know that you kind of get
what you pay for with respect to CPU
disk network as we build sites that are
increasingly more reliant on JavaScript
we sometimes pay for what we send down
in ways that we don't always easily see
so the shape of success there is what
can we do to send the least amount of
scripts to our users while still giving
them a useful experience now one of the
useful things that you can do to
accomplish that today one of the
greatest tools in your tool belt is code
splitting so code splitting is this idea
that instead of stripping down your
users a mouse
JavaScript monolithic bundle sort of
like a massive full pizza what if you
were to just send them one slice at a
time so the smallest amount of script
that they need just to get the current
page useful enough for them to use now
Co splitting can be done at a page level
at a route level at a component level
and this is something that's well
supported by many modern libraries and
frameworks it's well supported in web
pack so consider code splitting it's not
this sort of you know theoretical thing
either many large teams have been seeing
really great wins off the back of
investing in code splitting recently so
both Twitter and tinder as part of
rewriting their mobile web experiences
and trying to make sure that users are
able to interact with their sites as
soon as possible so anywhere up to a 50%
improvement in their time to interactive
just by adopting aggressive code
splitting inside their experiences
another thing that many of these sites
have done is adopted
auditing as part of their workflow
thankfully the javascript is going his
system has got a number of great tools
here so things like web pack bundle
analyzer which allows you to scan using
the source maps of your scripts all of
your dependencies that you're including
in your bundle and I helps you identify
sort of those places where you have
libraries that are perhaps larger than
you thought they might be you might have
NPM installed yourself into some
performance problems just because you
know you needed to ship something and
include a date library or a UI library
that was a little larger than you
thought it might be also great for
spotting places where you're including
duplicate code so just take advantage of
you know some of these tools for
auditing if you're really unsure whether
you have any issues with JavaScript
performance in general check out
lighthouse so lighthouse is one of those
tools by the chrome team that we've
baked into the chrome developer tools
it's also available as a Chrome
extension and the idea here is that it
gives you this really in-depth
performance analysis engine that will
highlight places where you can be doing
better one of the things we've recently
shipped in lighthouse is a feature
called JavaScript boot up time this
allows you to highlight places where
scripts might be spending quite a long
time in parsing and compiling and
executing so you can try to look at
opportunities to either you know split
up those scripts or just be doing a
little bit less work there another thing
you can do is try to make sure that
you're not shipping unused
down to your users something that's also
baked into chrome developer tools is
code coverage code coverage is really
useful because it allows you to just
load up your site inside a chrome and
then you can start interacting with your
pages and it'll highlight all of the
code that's actually been used or unused
on a per script level and as you start
interacting it'll actually update in
real time there's different bars to show
you know in red versus green how much is
unused versus used this can be really
great for identifying opportunities to
split up your scripts or in some cases
maybe no you know not even load them up
on initial load maybe they could be
deferred to the later point in time
so taking a look at production examples
where some of these ideas have been
useful I was talking to the Netflix team
last week and they mentioned that
there's this point where when you land
it on Netflix com they had a non-member
landing page flow that they wanted to
optimize they were initially using react
on both the server side and the client
side but they wanted to make sure that
their times interactive was as good as
possible and so what they ended up doing
was actually dropping react just for the
client-side portion we're still using it
on the server side but they pre fetched
it for subsequent navigations deeper
into the user experience this improved
their time to interactive by 50% which
is huge it meant that users could sign
up a little bit quicker and it was worth
the time investment here another thing
that Netflix mentioned was that there's
a point where they were trying to move
their video playback component so the
component that you see whenever you're
trying to play anything on Netflix from
vanilla JavaScript over to react so this
was the identical UI you know for both
versions of this thing and they
experienced some negative results
initially they found that the extra
JavaScript costs for downloading parsing
evaluating and the runtime costs for
using virtual Dom diffing we're quite
high and they ended up causing a few
negative results so reductions in play
hours reductions in usage and so they
ended up needing to spend a little while
actually reducing these costs to enable
them to finally roll out react for the
video player to I want it to highlight
what this actually looked like so here
we have an example using vanilla
JavaScript where there was no
interference on the main thread so your
interactive pretty quickly and then we
have a busy main thread example where
all of that JavaScript processing meant
that it took a few seconds before the
user could actually start interacting
with the video player as I mentioned
there thankfully in a much better place
now and they've been able to ship out
this experience to users but keeping an
eye on their time to interactive and
their JavaScript costs was critical to
them enabling future experimentation
that used react now if you're looking
for a pattern for serving JavaScript
efficiently to your users i heavily
recommend checking out purple or PR PL
so purple is a pattern that stands for
push render pre cache and lazy load and
it's a pattern for aggressively code
splitting where you just ship down the
kodi user needs for every single route
and then you take advantage of service
worker for pre caching the JavaScript
and logic needed for future routes and
lazy load it as needed what this means
is that when a user ends up navigating
to other views and the experience
there's a good chance it's already in
the cache and so they experience much
much reduced costs in terms of booting
this up and getting interactive so we've
talked about a few ideas you know if you
care about performance if you've ever
you know worked on our web page for your
site you know that sometimes you could
end up working on a fix coming back a
few weeks later and someone on your team
may have been working out a feature or
unintentionally you know broken the
experience you know you could be in a
position where you just fixed this site
and someone comes along you're like why
why did you ruin it
why thankfully there are ways that we
can we can try to work around this and
one way is having a performance budget
in place so performance budgets are
great because they keep everybody on the
same page it creates a culture or shared
enthusiasm for constantly improving the
user experience and it holds the team
accountable performance budgets can be
employed it's sort of a file size level
so you could have you know budgets based
on JavaScript chunks you could have
budgets around speed metrics so times
interactive or other metrics like first
content full paint this is a feature
this is an idea that is well supported
and tools like speed curve or calibre
and so if you're interested in trying to
get performance budget set up there are
none
you can try out just to roll this out
for your team heavily recommend it if
you're interested in trying to track the
cost of JavaScript in production for
your real users there are two things I'd
recommend checking out the first is the
long tasks API so this is an API that we
recently shipped in chrome allows you to
get gather real-world telemetry on
parsing compile as well as culprits
basically long tasks are any task that
lasts longer than 50 milliseconds that
could be problematic on the main thread
and you can record that and log it back
to your Google Analytics another thing
to check out is first input delay now
this is a metric that measures the time
from a user first trying to interact
with the experience and the browser's
are actually responding with something
so this is still an early metric we
actually have a polyfill available for
it today that you can go and check out
but between these two you should
hopefully be able to get enough to lemon
tree from real users to understand what
JavaScript performance problems they're
running into so improving performance is
a journey it's generally not something
you're just gonna do you know all in one
go and be done with it's usually a
journey where a lot of small changes can
actually lead to pretty big gains I
don't you know i don't expect most
people especially if they have
javascript performance problems to go
out and fix everything tonight you know
the III try to compare this to the
experience that you might have if
someone asked you to learn how to sketch
out something like a baby for example if
someone told you to go and learn how to
draw a baby you probably look up
tutorial and maybe the first step would
be drawing you know the outline the
second step is probably drawing the rest
of the baby but that's not the
expectation I have of ever anybody here
which you probably will do is you know
make a few incremental improvements to
your experience maybe you'll chip away a
little bit at the JavaScript and you may
end up here which is actually you know
not a bad place to be it's a little bit
better than the first one but over time
if you're able to continue investing in
improving the JavaScript performance of
your sites making sure that you're able
to get interactive really quickly your
users will thank you because they're
actually going to be able to do things
much much more quickly so I hope some of
that was useful that's it for me thank
you
you